Oh
[Music]
all right good afternoon everybody thank
you so much for coming to today's talk
my name is Colton Ogden I'm the course
instructor for GD 50 which is cs50 s new
introduction to game development course
we started this last spring and we've
been having lectures every week so far
for this last semester last week we took
a look at portal which is a famous game
by valve whereby you get a gun that can
essentially shoot these portals that
defy you know the laws of space on two
different services in the game walk in
and out of them and teleport through
them and see through them and there are
a host of interesting challenges
associated with implementing a game like
this now last week we looked at a simple
version of it in unity but today we are
joined by Dave Kircher and Tajik Kohli
of valve software who actually were on
the portal team and implemented all of
the interesting sort of design and
technical decisions that went about
making it work and making it fun and
believable so that any further ado this
is the portal problems thank you hi so
we're just going to run through so both
me and and Dave were actually students
when we were hired by valve and we were
hired to recreate like our the work we
did and as a student projects for valve
for portal 1 and for portal 2 and today
we just wanted to talk to you about some
of the issues we had trying to create
the mechanic for portals and then also
some of the design like the both the
technical and some of the design issues
that we tackle and work on to make the
to make the mechanic work properly so
Dave's going to start off and then I'll
jump in later hey folks as he mentioned
my name is Dave crusher
I was hired on specifically to work for
portal so I'm gonna go ahead and preface
we're jumping through a lot of topics
today and jumping very quickly so this
is a very video heavy presentation so
that we can jump quickly in and out and
I'm sorry if I go a little too fast I'm
kind of optimizing for the stream so
hopefully if you're if I've gone too
quickly over something you can review
the stream and see it the second time
so without further ado let's start off
just quickly I'm assuming that most of
the people here have played portal or at
least are familiar with it in some sense
that's just an assumption and that you
know for at least the technical portions
that you are at least somewhat
familiarize with 3d rendering if you're
not you may need to study up a little
bit and then come back but let's start
off with just what is a portal a portal
is a discontinuity in 3d space it's a 2d
discontinuity where we basically define
a 2d rectangle somewhere in space such
that the front faith are sorry the back
face of the 2-day rectangle is defined
as the front face of another 2d
rectangle so I've got my simple little
example here of this blue portal and
this orange portal we're defining them
to be back-to-back which gets us this
result over here so from the perspective
of this little portal guy it should look
like there's another room attached with
a cube in it but we're not actually
moving a 3d space at all because
otherwise if we're trying to make sure
that this perspective is true for both
this guy and the cube then you'd have
this weird overlapping space that
doesn't make any sense to anybody so we
do a lot of hacks to make it seem like
space is folding in these interesting
ways without actually moving space
another way to think of it is that it's
a door if you look closely at this
doorway it's a very standard door you
know it's door like you walk through it
different stuff happens but what I'm not
telling you initially is that this
actually isn't a door for technical
reasons this level required a portal
here because we needed this room to move
so even though it looks like a doorway
it's completely fake and that it's a
doorway that actually takes you about a
half mile across the level but it looks
like a door and so my job on the portal
series was to make sure that when when
we were when we're creating portals that
they feel to the player like a doorway
and if you think of in the term if you
think of them in terms of a doorway all
the interesting stuff for a portal
happens on the inside of the doorway and
nothing interesting happens on the
outside and it's my job to make sure
that all the interesting things that are
happening outside the door don't happen
because that's all stuff that doesn't
make any sense
so as you can see I just flew across the
level and that's the other side of that
door that we just looked at and I'm
walking through it and it's a doorway so
it's a door that doesn't take you a
couple inches it takes you about a half
mile across the level
so it's now we're into our rendering
section which is basically one of my
main expertise is in the portal area so
we're gonna be talking about quite a few
things and we're gonna jump in quickly
so hopefully I don't spew it out too
quickly that's kind of my my problem so
there are primarily two ways to render a
portal of view there might be more but
these are the to do that I'm primarily
familiar with the the preliminary way
that we did it with narbacular drop
which was the predecessor to portal was
with a rendered hit we've rendered the
texture and then when we got to working
on the portal franchise we've switched
to a method where you draw it all in a
single pass using what's known as a
stencil buffer and I'll be talking more
about that in a bit but there are
trade-offs to each method so with a
texture you have to have separate
texture per portal view and if you have
support for recursion you have to have
many many textures pre-allocated to do
this so your memory growth gets big very
fast you have to use the painters
algorithm or something like it to render
your portals you basically have to
figure out the deepest portal you can
see into and render that one first and
then any outward ones from that you're
gonna render them because they're going
to contain a view of that first portal
so you have to render it in that order
and I don't know if it's true anymore it
definitely was when I originally was
working on the first portal that you
couldn't effectively use anti-aliasing
so you get small visual artifacts as you
get close to a portal because it would
be rendered as a texture that doesn't
quite render the same way as the rest of
the back buffer and but it is the
simplest didn't implement especially if
you don't support recursion at all it is
super simple to do because you can
ignore the painters algorithm and just
render all of them before you do your
main view by contrast when we render
with stencils it renders the entire
frame to the back buffer so you don't
have any extra texture memory
requirements you're doing it all in a
single pass you starting from your main
view and working your way in you
actually have to nest it a little bit so
it's interesting you're guaranteed to
get homogeneous visual quality because
it's a single pass the way you're
rendering the rest of your frame and but
it has a lot of extra complexity of when
you render them and how you render them
so this is this rendering portion is
going to require quite a bit of spatial
thinking so I'm going to show you this
video bay
okay this is a layout I'm gonna use a
couple times is this playing hopefully
it's way yes okay this is a room layout
that I'm gonna use a couple times where
I've got an orange portal and a blue
portal and behind each one is a thin
wall with some stuff behind it but
hopefully to help illustrate what's in
front of the blue portal you can see
there's a whole bunch of blue stuff over
there and this year so yes that is the
example layout I want you to just kind
of keep in your head because spatial
thinking is important to actually have
reference let this finish one more time
okay now this is a something that
pertains to both rendering with textures
and stencils and I'm gonna let this play
once because I've advised that if I
front-load this too much it sounds
confusing so while I'm playing this I
want you to look at the fact that when
the orange portal is on-screen and when
it's not everything inside where the
orange oval is looks exactly the same
from when it is and when it is not there
and so what i'm doing here is as i'm
toggling between the views is I'm
teleporting to where the virtual camera
is that's regathering out of the the
orange portal whoops come on go back
okay I'm I'm talking back and forth I'm
looking into the orange portal but I'm
toggling to where the virtual camera is
behind the blue portal so if you
remember back to when I said that we're
we're defining the back face of one
rectangle to be the front face of
another rectangle that means that they
should be coplanar at all times and so
if you think of my my player model in
terms of locking it to the orange portal
when I'm rendering my exit view I should
end up behind the blue portal as I'm
rendering out of it so it's important to
remember that all the angles carry over
from that and most importantly that
whether you're rendering two textures or
rendering two stencil that nothing
inside ever moves because it should be
the exact same view angles the pixel
should be in the exact same place if
they're not in the same place your math
is wrong and this is especially
important when rendering with textures
because one of the first mistakes I have
seen several people do is that they
render the entire screen to a texture
and then they map the entire texture to
this
this little quad right here and it looks
all weird depending on how close or far
away you are but as long as you project
the as long as you product sorry trying
to work with videos is not the easiest
okay so if as long as you project where
the vertices of your your mesh are on in
screen space you can reuse those
coordinates in your as your texture
coordinates and then it'll line up
perfectly so that's the point of why
it's rendering is one-to-one is you just
want to make sure that you're rendering
the same parts to the same part of the
screen now I said I'd be using that
previous layout a bunch and I swear I'm
gonna get back to there but this is a
much better layout for rendering with
stencils and so you now you need to
learn a new layout just for a minute
it's only used in stencils but I've got
these two portals looking at each other
they're kind of one stacked on top of
the other and they've got these light
bridges they're just serving to show you
that transparencies are kind of a
special case so I'm gonna plate one more
time so you just got two portals facing
each other and they even though they're
tiny
it does make an infinite recursion down
into the portals
okay so rendering with stencils I'm kind
of assuming that for this part of the
talk that you have some idea what a
depth buffer is you may need to read up
on that if you don't the the stencil
buffer is very similar to the depth
buffer in that it defines rules and
operations for when we can wholesale
just not draw a pixel or when we do want
to draw it and then also while we are
drawing pixels you can define several
operations of how to modify the depth
buffer but for all intents and purposes
it's invisible to the user except for
the end result so stencil buffer a lot
like a depth buffer but it's you're
controlling the values in code instead
of by vertex depth so before we render
any scene using stencils what we're
gonna do is we're gonna clear our
stencil buffer at the same time as we
clear our def buffer we're gonna clear
it to all zero values and the depth of
the stencil buffer we were working with
with portal 1 I believe it only had two
bits I could be wrong it might be up to
8 bits but it's not a lot of bits so we
need to be very conservative with
LaValley as we get it put in there so
we're gonna clear it to zero so
everything in is zero and then we're
gonna raw render all the opaque objects
in our
and that's where we get to the visual
I'm showing you here so you'll notice
that none of light bridges are here none
of the cool fancy window stuff is here
so all we've done is drawn all the
opaque objects and then we take a
special detour to render a portal at
this point we've rendered this oval here
and while we're rendering the oval we
tell the rendering system to increment
the stencil buffer wherever we render a
pixel so while we're rendering all of
these pixels here go from 0 to 1 and
that's an important bit so we're gonna
be able to use that to tell the depth to
tell draw operations where to draw from
then on and then as soon as we've drawn
the the incrementing of the stencil
buffer we tell all draw operations from
then on to only draw where the stencil
value is 1 and we tell it to not modify
anything we're only drawing where
there's a 1 and then we can basically
just forget all the all about stencil
buffers for a little bit and keep
drawing but at this point if you've been
following along with the DEF buffer
we've already drawn this nice little
wall behind the portal so the depth is
the same as this little quad here and so
the first thing we do is we render a
full-screen quad with depth at maximum
value which does really effectively make
this a hole at this point and if we were
to continue drawing opaque objects and
things like that they would just show up
in this hole so then we start after we
have drawn after we've punched our hole
in depth and we've required that all
draw operations have this matching
stencil value of 1 then what we do is we
just start over in our main scene again
and just draw it again but this time we
move our virtual camera just the same
operation as I showed you in the
rendering is one-to-one we just have to
do a matrix transform such that we're
behind the blue portal and we draw it
again and so see here I think I have a
magnifying glass so you may notice that
we're in whoops okay
I can't apparently zoom and use a later
laser pointer so you may know the player
model is there and then the exact same
setup as I had shown you before it's the
same set of quads and the the oval again
and we do the exact same thing again we
tell it to increment so all the values
in this tiny little oval here are now 2
and then at that point we tell okay only
render
two pixels with a stencil value of two
and then we can just ignore stencil
buffers again we punched the hole again
and then we recurse again and we go into
a value of three at this point I'm gonna
get more into detail on it later but we
stop recursively rendering to stencil
buffers because otherwise we'd draw a
whole bunch of scenes that we're not
going to actually see we pull a little
trick that I'm gonna get into but so as
we've drawn all of our Opaques we would
theoretically do our detour we don't and
then we finished by drawing all of our
translucent objects and I know it's very
tiny to see in there but it'll become
more apparent later I think that sorry
that's actually our rendering trick and
there now we've actually draw the
translucence in that view and I know
this is very small but it'll make more
sense that recursion level one so as we
draw our translucent objects we're still
all confined to draw and we're stencil
value is two and then once we are done
drawing all of our translucent objects
we render the portal oval oops sorry
sorry sorry I'm gonna pretend that we're
drawing to the the big oval here because
it's easier to see we would we draw
another quad at this level sort of like
a window telling it to decrement the the
stencil value back to back to one I'm
sorry I need to take a step back we we
need to replace depth so that there's no
longer a hole there so we draw the
fullscreen quad with depth equal to the
portal plane while still restricting to
the the nested view and then we
decrement sorry so by the time we've
done decrementing that that means all of
these pixels inside this first recursion
are now one again every single one of
them is a one on the stencil value so we
can continue rendering the translucence
from the first recursion just like we
did when we doing the opaque so we can
say just restrict your drawing to all
stencil value one and then we finish our
translucence there we do the exact same
thing again while we're going back to
the main view we we fix up our depth and
then we recommend the stencil values
again and then we just finish out our
main scene and now you have portals
drawn using stencils then required no
extra texture memory whatsoever so
bouncing back to the scene that we had
shown before this
one of the things that we had to solve
pretty quickly is when you have a some
object in the middle of a portal it you
have to be able to see it in two places
at once and the way that we do this is
we literally just look up every piece of
rendering geometry it uses every texture
and replicate it and teleport it every
single frame to wherever the original is
and while we're replicating this object
over here you can see that it's slightly
more in front of the orange portal so
basically the rules are defined such
that whichever object whichever side of
the object has its origin in front of
the portal is the master and the origin
for these cube is right in its middle
and origin is just a term that we use to
define like the one point in space that
defines where this object is so usually
it's in the center of an object not
always but so that means this is the
real one and this is our complete and
utter fake one that we have to do for
every single object that is penetrating
the portal now when we duplicate
geometry and whether we not whether we
duplicate or not we have another problem
to solve I'm gonna let this video play
I'm gonna be toggling a broken part on
and off so when the cube is not behind
the wall
that's the fixed version and when you
can see it behind the wall that's the
broken version so if you think about
replicating geometry we have replicated
the entire model to this orange portal
which means all the stuff that that is
supposed to be in front of the blue
portal is also sticking behind this wall
because once again we have defined the
the two phases to be coplanar so what we
have to do is we have to use what's
known as a clip plane to tell the F
rendering system you know what just
don't draw any pixels if the mesh is on
this side this half of this half space
and we define the half space to be on
the portal plane and we can turn this
clip plane on and off as we're drawing
objects inside the portal plane and
that's what makes it work otherwise we'd
clip the whole world I'm gonna play the
video again it happens so yeah we're
just telling it hey you need to just
ignore every single pixel that's on that
half of all of space don't draw and that
makes it so it doesn't seem like it's
sticking out the back in weird ways that
people don't understand okay now this is
a very similar concept something that we
coined the term banana juice for even
back in or macular drop because it's
just confusing
and I know you're asking yourself what
in the heck is banana juice that doesn't
make any sense so we decided to use a
completely insane term for it because
even our technical shorthand for
describing the problem didn't accurately
describe what it was so we decided to
use a term that it was obvious that
explanation was needed so what we've got
here is I've got my orange camera and
I'm looking into the orange portal here
and that means I've got my blue camera
virtual camera here looking out of the
blue portal and if you remember back to
my example we've got this geometry
that's behind the blue portal and it's
between the the blue virtual camera and
the portal and if we render that it's
going to look completely broken
so banana juice is a term to define this
broken stuff that you would see if you
were looking behind a thin wall and I
have a video of it here
I believe I'm toggling back and forth
between views just like when I showed
you renderings one to one and that's me
turning off the clip plane this is what
it would look like if we were in the
virtual space and the clip plans were
not enabled and then I go back to our
main view and you'll see as I move
around in a second that it looks
completely broken and it kind of breaks
your brain if you don't understand
what's going on so that is banana juice
and you fix it exactly the same way as
with the entity clipping you have clip
models but what we do is I'm going to
replay the video here is if you're if
you're watching this entire part of the
level is now clipped so what we do is
while we're rendering a virtual camera
we just clip the entire world behind the
portal plane all of it everything that's
back there and yeah so that's how you
fix banana juice - it's not super
difficult once you understand it but I
can tell you it took me about two days
to figure out exactly what was going on
when I originally saw it it just didn't
make any sense
so moving on again I know we're jumping
a lot and I I'm sorry we're just gonna
keep moving on at a quick pace so
infinite recursion is something that
people kind of expected to see when they
were playing portal if you ever played
the original narbacular drop we didn't
support any form of recursion and it was
kind of a letdown
so I'm gonna go into how this works so
in this view you can see that we have
this blue portal that's our first
recursion right here and it's taking up
most of the screen
and then we've got this blue portal that
you can see the entirety of it that's
our second recursion and this one in
here is completely and totally fake so
that one there is no portal there
whatsoever what we're doing is we're
taking whatever we see of this portal
the second recursion we're taking that
exact view from the previous frame we're
taking that that those pixels and then
we're basically just doing a fix up in
case you moved your camera around and
we're applying the the texture
coordinates from the second portal to
where the third portal would be and by a
completely fake I mean we didn't even
render this blue oval that's that's just
a copy of this oval right here so it's
the exact same thing as if you point a
video camera out of at a video monitor
that's showing what it's recording you
know you get that feedback loop but we
have access to a little bit of extra
special math that means that we don't
get that weird sneaking effect if you
move it back and forth we can fix it up
quickly but this video is actually going
to show you about how this quickly
breaks down because if you're thinking
ahead you might be wondering what
happens if you can't see all the second
portal and the answer is that we stretch
it so as you watch the third one it just
kind of stretches off in weird ways
which is a problem that you know if we
spent a bunch of time we probably could
have fixed but in game development
sometimes you just call it good enough
and move on because I bet anybody that
played the original portal never notice
this whatsoever yeah
so another breakdown of it which I find
personally annoying and interesting at
the same time I'm just going to show the
video of it first is as I'm walking
you'll notice at the third recursion
where it's completely fake you're gonna
see a pop you just you're gonna see
every single time I walk through a
portal it pops around and so this is
actually fairly easy to explain once you
understand really understand how the
hack works so if you look at my
visualization here this is what the
actual recursion would look like if we
actually did it so we've got a couple of
portals here at these blue lines and so
inside our first portal that we're
fairly close to our field of view is
really wide and then as we get to our
second portal it gets really narrow
really fast but then as we get to the
third it narrows you
more and then the four that narrows even
more but since we're cutting and pasting
the second recursion if you look down
here on this visualization this is the
hack so we take this one the second
visualization and copy and paste it onto
the third on to the fourth and you can
notice that this doesn't converge at all
it doesn't narrow so we're seeing the
same amount of wall around each of the
reversions no matter what no matter how
narrow these this magenta cone is so as
we walk through a portal the the magenta
cone we're picking a portal that's
further off because now that's the
second recursion after we walked through
a portal so it starts off narrow which
is closer to what it should look like at
infinity it should narrowed you know to
basically where you're seeing a blue
tube but then as we walk closer and
closer to the the our main portal then
it's gonna widen and widen and widen it
so there's just a pop where it snaps
into place
so hopefully that made sense and once
again completely changing topics because
we've got so many things to cover so
when we're rendering portals we have to
have a mix of rendering first person and
third person so in this case you can see
I've got the my third person model over
here through this portal another third
person model over here and then we don't
see the it in the main view because I'm
about to turn it on it would look really
weird if you saw for the third person
view in the main view yeah I mean some
games do try to fix this with a very
special representations you know they'll
try to draw just the legs do something
like that but yeah so we have to kind of
have to have a complicated system to to
figure out when to draw a third person
and when to draw a first person and if
you were to guess I bet you would say
well just render a third person every
time you look through a portal and it
turns out it's slightly more complicated
that I'm not actually gonna get into the
complicated version but I'm gonna show
you how it's broken if you use that
simple rule because why would life be
easy and we would just be able to render
just when we're on the other side of a
portal so in this case let me look up so
you'll notice in this case I'm on a
tilted angle and this is a case where my
feet are on one side of a portal and my
eyes are on the other side of a portal
so it kind of breaks the original system
that would say oh just render if you're
on the other side of a portal
and so yeah it's a little more
complicated not terribly it should
actually look way more broken than this
but we actually had the fix in several
places and this is a special build where
I had to go back and break things and I
only broke it in one place yeah okay and
then the last on our rendering portion
so earlier I had talked about how we
need to duplicate geometry that is on
that is mid portal but there's also
another thing that we need to duplicate
which is there are screen space effects
where we can query draw operations and
things like that and so one way that we
use these draw operations that are in
screen space is to determine how much
light glare to use around these lights
and so how these work are you basically
we draw a quad while we're drawing the
light and then we say okay in a couple
frames I want you to tell me how many
pixels actually drew and we're not
allowed to actually query this
immediately because of pipeline reasons
we don't have the results for several
frames so we have to cash off that
handle that says how many pixels did you
draw and we'll get the result at some
point later sometimes you're lucky and
it's just one frame but usually two or
three frames so you have to save it for
a while but you may notice that even
though we're not replicating the the
geometry of the light we're drawing two
of them because they're in screen space
so that means that this query system had
to be smart about it and I'm going to
show how we we have two separate results
now if we had used the engine as it was
originally written there would be just
one query for one light but then that
would mean that these lights would dim
in unison so we need to have separate
buckets for each view of portals and
every view query that portal that any
view query that is issued while in that
recursion we have to keep it in a
totally separate bucket and then call it
back later and then as we walk through
portals we have to transfer those
buckets so like if I were to walk into
the blue portal at this point all of
those handles we have to transfer to the
main view and then all the ones that are
from the main view we transfer into what
was now orange because we would be
walking out of this orange one if we
walked into the blue so yeah that is the
the quick set of rendering things I
wanted to cover so now I'm going to hand
it off to my
my colleague to jeev to talk a bit about
design give your spatial thinking a bit
of a rest yeah so that was a lot of a
lot of technical stuff about rendering
of portals and you can see it's like
it's it's more complex than it seems at
first the naive solution seems like
we'll get you most of the way there but
then as you start putting in more things
in the game and more ways the player can
interact with the game you see there's a
bunch of different complexities that you
have to account for and a lot of those
complexities are not just in a technical
sense but also from a design sense so I
just want to talk through some of the
issues that we came up with as we were
making portal 1 and 2 and some of the
ways we try to solve them one of the
first things I want to mention was when
first coming up with the idea for
portals before figuring out if we should
spend a bunch of time making making this
idea like this game new game mechanic
that most people haven't seen before
what we did was we or Dave and his team
made a prototype of a portal in a 2-d
game engine that is used in to Japan
while while they were students and it
was made in there and the in-house to
depend to the engine and you can see
here that it's a it's a 2d version of
portal but it still got all the basic
game mechanics that are used in portal
and it's like the main goal of doing
something like this is to like wear out
the mechanics and you see if they're
still fun at their core and part of what
you do here is is you play test right
you you make this simple prototype and
you get other people to try it out and
play it and say hey is this fun is this
something that we should spend the next
of like our next year working on as a
proper 3d game and the prototype you can
see had most of the basic functionality
there and kind of vetted out the idea of
the mechanic to take it forward and as
as we take the mechanic forward one of
the first things that you realize
is this is a brand-new mechanic that
people don't really understand and you
have to train them in a like train them
with how the mechanic works and also
train them with sufficient knowledge so
they can use that mechanic to solve
puzzles which is the core of the game
and one of the things that we did is you
have to have certain sections of the
game where you can be sure that the
player has the knowledge that they need
to progress so a lot of this is about
making sure that the levels of designing
are done in such a way that when the
player finishes that level they have
that knowledge that you want them to
have and one of the ways we we kind of
ensure that is through doing a lot of
play testing and play testing is
something I'll talk about a little more
as the talk goes on but the basic idea
of play testing is just getting someone
else to play the game and that someone
else could be a co-worker who sits next
to you your friend your anyone else
really like anyone that some someone you
get specially to come play play the game
from outside the company but usually
it's just your co-workers people that
sit next to you people that see you work
on the game and but don't know exactly
what you're doing and you just kind of
observe them and see what they're doing
get some feedback from them and then use
that that data and iterate on the
mechanic and you can see here so this
was this was a level in in Portal 1 it
was pretty early on this level and you
can see the portals here the blue portal
here is moving on a timer it moves from
one to the next the next and the idea of
this level was by the time player solve
this they understand that I go in one
portal and come out the other right that
that's the basic idea here and in portal
1 this level did a pretty good job of
teaching players that for portal 2 we
have a very similar puzzle I'm going to
just have it play here it's a pretty
similar puzzle right the idea is the
same thing you have the three sections
where the portals can go the one change
we made here was we moved the portal
away from a timer and moved it to
buttons so this way the player has more
control of where the portals are opening
there's a few reasons for there
the main one here is like the level in
Portal 2 has a lot more visual noise
there's a lot more like it's an old
level a lot of foliage a lot of
destroyed stuff so it's not as clean as
portal 1 and also there's a case of in
portal 2 there's a lot of people that
have already played portal 1 and are
probably already familiar with the
mechanic so we don't want them to have
to go through the timers and wait for
all the things to happen even though
they know how it works so this way they
can just go in and and show us that they
know how the portals work without having
to wade through all the timers and the
basic goal is the same thing that by the
end of this level were confident that
the players understand how portals work
one of the other things that you learn
through play testing is you learn what
you need to teach the player there's
some times when you'll be making the
game and there's certain things that you
as a designer or as a creator won't
think are our challenging concepts or
are things that need to be talked to
players explicitly one of those things
that we noticed early on is this concept
here where a lot of players kind of
thought portals were one way that you go
in one and you come out the other and
that's it
but they have to be taught that you can
actually go in both ways you can go in
the blue one and come out the orange or
you can go in the orange one and come
out the blue one and so this this puzzle
specifically does that where the blue
one is the only one that you're moving
so the orange one stays stationary first
you go in the blue one you come out the
orange one replace the blue one and then
you go in the orange one and come out
the blue one so the idea with this again
is is you have to figure like through
play testing is what you is how you
figure out the different things the
different discrete small things that you
need to teach the player and then also
try to figure out how to teach them in a
way where they're figuring it out
instead of you telling it to them so for
the most part in in portal 1 & 2 there's
certain things that we tell the player
but for the most part we want them to
figure it out and have like have that
epiphany themselves because then they
learn it if you just tell it to them
they might not take in the exact
knowledge another thing here is this was
a level in Portal 2 but we noticed
through one of our play tests I was
through a few feet of our play tests
that players were super hesitant to
place portals on the floor even though
this level is probably the fifth or
sixth one in the game and you've done
that a few times in the game before this
but usually you're doing it way down
there and like doing a fling
it's a fling mechanic where you like fly
through the portal and come out so
players have placed portals on the floor
before but they they haven't done it
right at their feet so we had to design
a scenario here where the only way
forward like this urine is trapped in
this black room with nothing else and
the only thing you can do is place a
portal on the floor there and that's one
of the things that that you realize as
as you keep testing and is you'll you'll
come across players of different skill
levels and different knowledge of video
games and different knowledge of how
controls work and typically you you want
to make sure that you're not only
catering to the low end or the high end
you want to make sure that both both of
them can't have a good time at your game
so you want to design puzzle gates in a
way that aren't super intrusive if a
player that sees this gate here already
knows that I can place portals on floor
and go and go by this doesn't seem like
anything that's stopping them this just
seems like part of the level but to a
new player that comes in here and it's
like I don't know how to proceed it
takes them a while to figure it out and
then when they have that aha moment they
feel pretty smart about it so you want
to make sure that you're you're
designing stuff in a way that isn't
frustrating players that already
understand the mechanics but also isn't
making players that don't understand the
mechanics have to like like figure they
have to be super frustrated as well
another thing that we had to do so
portal 1 & 2 both have this mechanic
where you go into a portal on the floor
and come out one on the wall and it like
keeps your momentum and your velocity
and flings you forward one of the things
we noticed while we were
working on this mechanic is that there's
a lot of times when players don't
exactly quite line up as their fall into
the portal which means that when they
fall in they're not going to fall out
they're not going to come out the portal
on the wall in a correct way
and a lot of times players won't know
that they had the right solution they
just kind of messed up the execution a
little bit and we want to try and help
the players in these cases but again try
to be not intrusive about it because you
want to make sure that the players as
they're solving puzzles they're not
thinking that they had a right solution
but it didn't work the first time I
tried it so now I have to rethink the
whole solution even though the solution
was correct the first time so one of the
things we used we used a few different
things to help the players out in this
way and again with the idea of them
being mostly invisible to the player
there aren't always completely invisible
and in some cases we have ways to opt
out of them but this is one of the
things that we used so if you notice
here the player is going to drop through
the orange portal but as you notice as I
walked through walk forward here I'm
purposely not going to fall exactly
straight and one of the mechanics we you
had in the game was it was pretty subtle
there but I'm going to do it again
you'll see I'm walking to the side and
the game kind of funnels you into the
portal so we had the special thing we
used in portals for portals that are
most on the floor most facing mostly up
imagine there's like a cone coming out
of the portal and if you're falling from
some height and if you're within that
cone and the cone kind of it's not super
wide it's pretty narrow if you're within
that cone then we kind of funnel you
into the center of the portal so that
when you're coming out of it you're
going to be lined up perfectly with it
and as you can see the third time I did
it there it didn't happen because the
way this works is that it only works if
you're looking at the portal so it works
the second time with the third time I'm
going to go mostly in the same direction
and it's not going to work so that's
that's our way of kind of trying to make
these things be not intrusive to where
if players don't expect
to go in that portal it's not going to
work but if the player is looking at a
portal and they expect to go in it we
kind of nudge them along a little bit
and you can see it here in and this is a
second case of the same thing where
that's a portal on the floor and ceiling
and you can see as the funnel is working
the players perfectly in the center of
it but I'm going to look forward a
little bit and disable the funnel and
you can see the players gonna go off
access because the fun will get disabled
and the player slowly went out of it
so now yeah the funnel is disabled now
and again the idea of this is to reduce
a bunch of the player of frustration and
to reduce a bunch of the false negatives
that players get you want to make sure
that players that think they got the
solution and if it was the correct
solution you want to kind of help them
out a little bit you don't want to solve
the puzzle for them you don't want to
give them like here's the answer but you
do want to try and help them out a
little bit and because that helps that
that makes the game a little bit more
fun and and reduces the frustration so
that was that was a help where we had
for when you're entering portals we also
have the opposite and that was that was
there in portal 1 and in portal 2 we
introduced something that was the
opposite of a helper which we use when
you're coming out of portals so portal 2
had this mechanic called Ariel fate
plates which is pretty straightforward
you step on this fate plate and it
propels you to the air and the level
designers can place the the Fate plate
on the level and can kind of control the
trajectory of the arc of where the
player is going to fly and this arc is
not really visible to the player but
it's pretty apparent based on the level
design so you can see in this one I'm
going to play the video as I'm talking
and then maybe play it a couple times so
there the tech that was developed for
these aerial faith plate it's something
that we reused for like a fling helper
so you can see here there's all these
faith play I'm going to turn on some
debug draw and you can see right here so
this green arc here is the arc that's on
the faith plates but you can see there's
some
coming out of the walls there as well so
this was a part of the level where the
player is gonna fling out of he's gonna
fling a box out of that actually because
we want this to work for objects as well
as the player so you can see as the box
goes through here and then here these
are this fate plates and then when the
box comes out of that we kind of have
the box follow the arc that's kind of
predetermined because that's that's I
think what the player is expecting at
that point they expect it to have solved
a solution solve the puzzle
but the the funnel the the trigger here
this kind of corrects the arc to make
sure that it's always going to go in the
place the player expects and we also
have a case of the same things working
for the player so you can see here
there's two different arcs that are
coming out because we've kind of doubled
up the the triggers over here the way
these triggers worked in the game is
they won't always enable when the player
touches them they require a minimum
velocity threshold so the player has to
be doing most of the work right so the
player has to be has to have figured out
a way in the level to the to the puzzle
design to get that velocity but we know
that there's some differences in physics
and differences and the exact mechanism
you might use so we're just saying if
you've got the minimum velocity that we
require we're gonna take you all the way
there so in this one you can see we have
the two different cases so if I just
fall out of the portal it's not gonna
activate any of them if I somehow
managed to get some velocity it's gonna
activate the failed case one and take me
there and the reason we have the failed
case one is because we wanted we want to
make sure that if players somehow get
most of the velocity but like bonked on
the wall they don't keep thinking that
they can that's the correct way to do it
so we want to make it obvious that you
failed so it's again the same way we
have to help Mia like helping the
players out but not by giving them the
solution just by making it obvious that
the thing you did was correct or wrong
and then if you do the correct way in
this level which is to get velocity
doing that and then you make a portal
there
you're gonna do the correct thing and
fling out of it and again that the main
idea here is to get rid of those false
negatives is like especially here
because there's a few different spots on
the wall that you can put the portal and
we don't really want to restrict a lot
of that and just put the one square on
the wall that is the solution square
because again if you put the portal down
here I put the portal up here the ark is
gonna be slightly different so this the
this mechanism we had just kind of
corrects those arcs and make sure that
it goes in the one or two ways that we
want another thing we added in this will
added in portal 2 was a highlight for
your portals so you can see where your
portals are placed through walls and
this is something that's super useful in
levels where you have to keep track of
which portal you placed over there so
you know which one to place over here
because sometimes it's like okay I just
got out of the blue one and the orange
ones over there so if I place the blue
one again oh I got to do the whole
puzzle again now cuz I place the wrong
one so this helps a lot and just making
sure that you're you know where your
portals are so you can be like I want to
come out of that one so I'm going to
place the other one and there's
something we added in portal 2 and it
was pretty helpful and it's also helpful
in in the co-op version of the game
because in the co-op one you want to see
where both the players portals are at
all times and this mechanic helps in
that another thing we added to kind of
help the player a little bit is a thing
we call the placement helper and this
was not used a whole lot in the game but
there's a few sections in the game where
we want to we want to encourage the
players to come out of a portal in a
particular direction so we have these
things that we placed in the level with
a certain radius and if you place a
portal within that radius we just kind
of snap it to the direction to the
center of it but they're on a timer so
if you place one portal and you're like
oh I actually want to place it over here
you can always opt out of it and that's
again when I was talking earlier you
want to add some
excuse me you want to add these helpers
in a way that for players that they're
mostly invisible to most of the players
but the players that want to opt out of
them have a way of opting out of them so
[Music]
so you can see the first portal that's
placed does get snapped but the second
one that's placed goes exactly what the
player wanted and we used these in a few
spots in the game but they weren't used
a whole lot because for the most part
you want to have you want to make sure
the player feels like they're in control
and one of the other things that was a
lot of fun while making portal and Dave
will talk a lot about this excuse me
we'll talk a lot about this later is the
physics of portals or physics of objects
interacting with portals and for the
most part we're trying to be super
accurate with it right we're trying to
make stuff work the way players expect
in in real life because that's kind of
what we're trying to simulate here but
one of the things that we thought that
we added here that we thought was more
fun than accurate so you can see the
window sorry I'm a little bit sick you
can see here that when the box starts
off it's just resting on the floor so
it's got no initial velocity whatsoever
so when you place the blue portal down
the expectation is probably that it
keeps resting there or maybe it goes in
the center of the portal and just stays
there but that's not a super fun game
mechanic so here we just have it be so
that objects coming out of portals have
some minimum velocity so they're always
have some minimum velocity and this
works also for other parts of the game
like the like the paint and you can see
here that like there is some air
resistance that takes place and the
paint does slowly come down but once it
comes down to its minimum velocity it
just stays there and this is like it's
like completely fabricated fiction like
it's there's no like this real physics
for this it's just kind of like this is
more fun than trying to simulate real
fiction real
so you can see here like it's like air
resistance is making it go down like
they're slowing down but once they get
to the minimum velocity to stay there
yeah this is about it so once it gets
here it's just gonna stay here it's not
gonna go below that and speaking of gels
the gels actually came for an idea that
we had for a student game that we made
while we were in the Japan it was called
tag the power of paint and in tag you
had a paint gun that you used to shoot
the different colors and the portal 2
mechanic was adapted from this and it's
pretty similar but one of the things we
did get rid off from for portal 2 was
the idea of having the paint gun because
one of the core ideas we had while
working on portal 2 was that any any
mechanics we add to the game should
really work with portals and should
really interact really like at a core
level with portals so we thought instead
of using the gun to move the paint
around it would make much more sense to
use the portals to move the paint around
and and that was kind of cool not just
with the gels but with any new mechanic
we added to the game was that portals is
is the core idea of the game so
everything we do should kind of center
around how portals work and this is just
showing you the different colors we had
and in tag one of the colors that we
added in Portal that wasn't there in tag
was the portal gel and this is again
going with the idea of how do we make
the gels and portals interact better so
this one just lets you spread around
like white paint so you can put portals
anywhere that the paint can go and this
is a pretty cool mechanic in that it it
allows for a lot more open-ended level
design and a lot more player freedom
because you can place portals
essentially anywhere now because for a
lot of the game we're restricting where
the players can put portals on the black
surface or the white surface and this
just allows like you can put white
anywhere and put portals anywhere we
didn't use this a whole lot because it
is pretty open-ended and does break a
lot of puzzle design but there are a few
cases where we use it and in a pretty
open-ended way and have the player just
kind of have fun
spend some time like painting the whole
level and like figuring out what to do
and these these kind of levels have
usually have a couple of different
solutions because we don't know where
the player is gonna paint so we just put
a bunch of different ways to get to the
exit and players like some players
figure out all the marks some players
find the first one and just go there and
it helps it it helps to break up the
pacing a little bit from the
conventional puzzle design with the
specific spots where like here's some
white spots here's some black spots so
it helps break that up a little bit one
of the things that didn't make it
through from our student game was the
sticky gel that you saw in the in the
student version so this is going to look
a little bit broken because this is from
a really old version of portal 2 because
this sticky gel got cut pretty early on
and you're gonna see some stuff here
that doesn't really make sense but just
go with it so you can see like the we
use purple instead of blue here so you
can jump on you can walk on walls and
stuff which is pretty cool so here you
can see there's blue paint coming out of
there but you can't see the actual paint
blobs because they're invisible for some
reason I couldn't figure it out but you
can see the actual paint on the walls on
the floor so this is just an idea of the
kind of puzzles we were trying to come
up with using the sticky paint there's
an extra portal gun for some reason
ignore it this is a really old version
of the game so this is the kind of
puzzles we're trying to come up with of
combining the different paint colors and
and portals together but we we did end
up cutting this feature though when but
there were a few different reasons one
of them was obviously it is it is quite
disorienting you can see like going up a
wall and like trying to figure out where
the ceiling is where the floor is
especially in a lot of these levels
where that they're mostly just black and
white
it gets pretty disorienting and we had
more than a few play testers complaining
about that but the other big reason that
we
that we cut it is because I didn't
really interact well with portals you
don't really want to walk into a level
and have the pots already placed for you
and like there's no real good way to
make pots on the entire wall without
having to place the portal like 50 times
and also it didn't really interact well
with the portal player physics and
portal physics and they will talk some
more about the player physics through
portals and this is one of the things
that you can see we had a paint gun for
a little bit but we ended up cutting it
so you can see I'm painting the wall
over here I don't want to walk on the
wall but as I enter the blue portal you
can see like it's just not letting me go
through but if I go to this way it works
and that's just one of the things that's
like well we gotta solve this we can't
ship like this we gotta solve the
problems and we spent some time trying
to work on these issues but at some
point you realize that the you're not
guaranteed to solve these problems no
matter how long you spend on them so at
some point you gotta just be like okay I
don't want to spend an extra month or
two trying to fix these problems not
knowing if you'll get there and plus
there's other reasons why the mechanic
isn't working out so let's just stop
working on this and work on other stuff
instead another thing we ended up
cutting from this was from portal one
that was present in never a clear drop
was the ability to place portals through
portals and it's a pretty confusing
thing and that was the main reason we
cut it because most players just thought
it was way too confusing because you're
placing the blue portal by looking
through the orange portal here so the
blue portal is like he's pointing
through the orange portal here and
placing the blue portal over here
because the other blue portal is behind
him and it's just like this is too
confusing and also it doesn't there's
not a lot of puzzle design that you lose
by disabling this feature you do like
the thing you do gain is like players
aren't getting super confused and also
you're not and I cut not necessarily
cutting a bunch of puzzles that you
can't make now so this feature got cut
as well and this is something that we
generally cut but we stopped using in
Portal 2 that was used
a little bit in Portal one was the idea
of a double fling and I'm gonna show it
here so double swing is basically
placing a portal while you're falling
out of a portal and it's one of those
things that like it works pretty well
and it's a pretty cool mechanic and it
was used in a few spots in portal 1 a
couple of puzzles required like this
puzzle here requires you to do this
double thing but one of the things we
noticed was a lot of players have
difficulty in executing a lot a lot of
these super high precise like high
precision movements even though they
know what the solution on the puzzle is
so players will walk walk in this room
and figure out like okay I got to do
this I got to do that and and it's gonna
work but then a lot of players have
trouble like walking out of affordable
making a portal quickly and like it's
it's adds a lot of stress and we wanted
to move away from a lot of the twitch
movement based stuff and towards more of
a kind of aha I got it that kind of
stuff and once you get it we don't want
you to spend a bunch of time in like
making sure you get the precise
movements right so this feature we
didn't really cut it it's still a
mechanic that works in Portal 2 but none
of the puzzles in portal 2 required
anymore and once we added the level
editor a lot of the puzzles people are
making do required and a lot of players
like it but it's not something that we
thought we wanted to make sure like make
everyone have to do and another thing
that we changed from portal 1 to portal
2 was these energy balls these energy
balls at the time I mean part of the
reason we use them in portal 1 was
because they were there in half-life and
it was a it was an already created
mechanic that we had that we could just
rip from them but the basic mechanic is
these things fire these things fire this
ball that bounces around and it needs to
go in this receptacle here it's under my
gun right now it needs to go and this
was septic you'll hear and once it goes
there it finishes the puzzle there's a
few issues with this mechanic though in
that there's a bunch of timing element
involved here because the ball takes
time to travel and also if you get hit
by it
you die
which I mean it's fine it's a game
mechanic but if I'm for portal 2 we just
start like how can we improve on this
idea and the thing we came up with was
using lasers instead of the energy ball
so here you can see it's the same level
from portal 1 and you can even see the
energy Ball dispenser going away and
being replaced by a laser because we
want to make sure like player like
GLaDOS is improving these mechanics now
and and got better versions of it and so
the laser effectively is very similar to
the energy ball right like it goes in
one and you want it like it goes in over
here and you want it to go to the
receptacle over there the big advantage
here is that the the reaction is instant
so if the players got the solution or
not it's instantaneous you don't have to
have situations where you place the exit
portal and now you have to wait for the
ball to go all the way across the level
and see if it lines up or not this way
it just instantly does it plus it also
opens up a bunch of different gameplay
opportunities because now you can use
multiple relays in the same level you
can have the cube that do redirects the
laser so overall it felt like an
improvement over the energy ball and
talking about about lasers so so far
we've been talking about a bunch of
these smaller decisions we made to solve
these smaller problems as they kept
coming up like entering exiting portals
making sure things are lined up or not
improving on the specific game mechanics
but one of the things that you need to
do when you're trying to make a whole
game is to see how these mechanics come
together and how how you can combine
them together to make a whole game to
make a few puzzles that increase in
difficulty complexity and go to towards
some crescendo and the one of the ways
we did that is by kind of using this
kind of process that I'm going to go
through and we use it a couple times
both in portal 1 and in portal 2 and
there's a few different mechanics that
we use this cycle over and over for and
that's kind of how the entire game track
is designed so it starts off with
introduction and the introduction is the
puzzle we just showed you that's the
that's the intro puzzle for lasers and
it's really straightforward it just
shows you the mechanic he goes in one
portal kind of the other goes in a
receptacle it's really straightforward
introduces a mechanic most people won't
get tripped up on this from there we
then try to saturate the player with
that same mechanic we introduce
different twists on that same without
introducing the whole new mechanics we
just introduce different kind of
versions different tweaks on that same
idea so this room still only has lasers
but now that you introduced relays and
cubes and you can like experiment figure
it out figure out how to connect the
three layers relays together figure out
how to move the cube figure out how to
move the port the laser through the
portals but still it's only lasers
nothing super complex yet then we give
you more of that we give you more of
just the same mechanic here there's two
things firing lasers and two things you
got to connect and so it's it's the same
idea it's like just using lasers but not
super complex just like building on the
complexity by little by little followed
by a puzzle that's like okay this is the
puzzle that's gonna teach you all about
lasers bar now you've seen lasers in a
few different different ways this one
once you get this you understand how
lasers work you know everything there is
to know about how lasers work so this
puzzle here excuse me there's two cubes
and three things firing lasers and on on
the other side of the puzzle there's
three things you got to connect them and
this puzzle is very difficult but by
this point you've been slowly introduced
different ideas of how lasers work and
this one kind of taking them all
together and then once we've done that
then we start combining them then we
start taking okay now you've got a laser
and different cube and a bridge and and
by this point you've seen like a whole
separate we've done the whole
introduction saturation graduation track
with bridges as well so by this point
you go in there and okay I know how
bridges work I know how lasers work how
do they work together like how do I
combine them together and then we just
start escalating from there and then you
go into this puzzle that has a bridge
has a laser has a turret has some cubes
coming out has a catapult has a bunch of
the stuff but by the time the player get
here they're not really overwhelmed by
it because they've been introduced to
all these mechanics separately and also
smaller combinations of them so that
when they get to this point where
there's a bunch of different mechanics
they know how they all work individually
and that's kind of the process that we
use of slowly ramping up the difficulty
first with a single mechanic then by
combining them and then that's that's
kind of how we take the individual
smaller design elements and combine them
together and turn them into the whole
game and now I think Dave's gonna come
back and talk some more about physics
and after I cover these last four bits
of physics we're gonna open up for
questions I know we have a whole
miscellaneous section that we've
outlined here but that's more just
buffer material so hoping you're gonna
put your spatial thinking caps back on
so how we handle portal transitions is
there's two distinct methods one is that
we've got volumes here which we call
touch volumes or trigger volumes and
those are centered around the portal so
I've got my blue portal here I've got
this green volume here and you'll notice
it's entirely in front of the portal
that's important and then I got this
yellow volume here so the yellow volume
is just it's a whole job is to tell us
which objects in the world are just kind
of close to a portal and I'll come back
to why that's important in a minute
but it separates us from having to think
about objects that are way out in the
world you know all over in the white
space around here just we don't have to
think about them and we also know
they're not objects behind the portal
because we're only interested in stuff
that happens in front of the portal and
this green volume here is where most of
the magic happens this volume says the
objects in it are so close to a portal
we need to think very hard about what
they can do what they can't do we're
gonna let those objects start passing
through the portal and so we keep these
objects in two separate lists objects
that are in this green volume no longer
intersect with any objects out in the
white space out here they don't have to
think about them they're kept in a
completely separate list and they don't
collide with them at all they also don't
collide with world geometry
I'll get to that in a bit and then
objects in this yellow volume are the
only ones that the objects in the green
volume have to worry about so these are
objects that are just kind of close to a
portal and so another important
interaction with portals is raycasting
so we're only interested in rays that
pass through the portal quad so if a ray
happens to just pass the portal plane
but not intersect the quad we don't do
anything with it it's not special we
just treat it like any other ray in the
world and let it do its merry thing but
we got this magenta guy it intersects
with the portal so now we have to recast
a new ray out the other orange portal
which essentially gives us to race
Eggman's and if you think about that
if you were to write any piece of code
that just did the ray casting and hand
back to race Eggman's where somebody was
expecting one you're probably gonna get
weird results so this means this the
fact that this is happening means that
we have to go through every single
system in the game that possibly cast
array through a portal and fix every
single one to understand but if we give
you back multiple segments different
things happen instead of you know
assuming that like this starting point
goes directly to this end point and
which doesn't even go in the direction
it wanted to in the first place and so
at its core remember how I told you how
every object had a origin a single point
that defines it where it is in space we
use the Ray casting to determine if an
object that's in this green volume and
just kind of moving around we use a ray
cast from one point where it was one
frame to one point where it was another
frame to see if it either passed through
the portal or outside the portal because
if it went over this way we do nothing
at all if we went this way we need to
teleport it so that's the basics of our
handling now so how do we let objects
pass through walls this is one of the
things I spent a whole lot of time on
because we wanted our portal transitions
to be very seamless remember one of my
first slides I showed you it should be
like a door people expect to walk
halfway through a door and just stand
there and how we do this is I'm going to
talk about it a bit first is we take
whenever you place a portal we take a
snapshot of all the world geometry
around you and create a very small
representation of that and carve a hole
in it and we don't do this for the
entire world because that takes way too
long and by way too long I mean a
a second and in game terms that's just
way too long so why I don't know if it
was a quarter second I remember
originally that we had a problem where I
think carving the mini version took a
quarter of a second so it probably takes
several seconds so I'm gonna show you a
scenario here where I've got a portal
and it's going into it's going along
this this corridor gateway gangplank
thing and it's going to go into this
little classroom area and as I go back
around the wall I'm going to show you a
bug mesh of our collision representation
now
so in this debug representation we've
got these green lines these green lines
and then also these cyan lines or I'm
probably mispronouncing that I call them
blueish but my colleague has told me I
need to call him cyan so I'm gonna call
blueish now so these these green lines
and the blue lines are in local space so
there with the blue portal that we
placed locally and I know it's super
hard to see but there are a bunch of red
lines over here and some magenta ones
those are from the other portal that's
in the classroom that are flipped and
glued to the back of our local portal so
it's all in this local space around this
blue portal we put some new stuff behind
it and some new stuff in front of it and
so you may be asking yourself what the
colors actually mean Green here is
representing a brush geometry which most
level editors you can create walls and
various shapes directly in the level
editor and in in at least in our
terminology we refer to these as brushes
so there are usually very simple convex
shapes and super easy to deal with and
this this bluish geometry is from a
what's known as a static prop which is a
model that somebody modeled in a model
editor so it can be arbitrarily complex
but it has to be made up of convex
shapes but we take a small snapshot of
that and then kharbut oh sorry I forgot
to mention us so we call it a static
proper because we are guaranteed it does
not move and that's very important
because it's really easy to simulate
things that don't move they don't move
so and the same is this the same is true
of the red and magenta here the red is
the brush geometry on the paired portal
side and the magenta is brush aesthetic
props on the other side which is namely
the desks and as I'm looking through
here you can see just just a small
snapshot huh a small snapshot and then
also you can see you can see this
magenta outline here of the the desk
mesh on the other side it's important to
know that that's not me looking at the
mesh through the portal that's the local
space version and it just happens to
line up the desk because we have to make
sure everything lines up otherwise your
physical interactions will seem weird if
something is halfway in a portal and
it's kind of not colliding with
something or it's colliding with it
wrong and as I walk through you'll
notice all the colors change because we
switched faces when I walk through one
is a second so now all the colors are
local space first this side so yeah that
is how we carve a hole it's a very very
small area the level that we carve a
hole in and so we're getting back to the
volumes I showed you two slides ago we
if we carve a small representation of
the world we have to know when the
players colliding with that versus the
regular world because if they're
colliding with the regular world they're
going to collide with the wall that's
behind the portal and they're not gonna
go through it so we have to use
exclusively that carved version when
they're close to a portal and we do that
using the same volumes I was talking
about earlier this is the 3d
representation of them and you'll notice
that they have spaced a large amount of
space above and below the portal that's
important because you know it's 3d space
instead of a 2d space so as I entered
the the yellow space i I still collide
with the world I still collide with all
the the desks and things because I'm
still while I'm in exclusively in the
yellow volume I am still colliding with
the world I'm gonna show you it's a bad
example but it's the video I've got I'm
gonna hit this this chair behind this
desk because it's still in the real
world and then as I transition into the
green volume I am exclusively colliding
with the are carved version of it which
wasn't a bad for him to cut if I'm
having to look back in the portal which
side is scrubbing okay
sorry so if you happen to look inside
the portal you might be able to see it
there is I know it's super hard to see
I'm sorry but there we did carve a hole
there's no there's no geometry right
here to stop us going in and we're since
we're exclusively using this new mesh
we're allowed to just go through that
space okay so more importantly than
static geometry which doesn't move and
is super easy to physically simulate we
have dynamic props and things that move
specifically in this case boxes so the
way we model this is very similar to how
we did with geometry we're going to be
duplicating everything and I'm gonna
show you by walking of the portal so
this blue box that just appeared is my
player my player physics object that's
replicated from this orange portal to
the backside of the blue portal and this
is using a system of known as a physics
shadow at least that's what our system
is I'm not really a physicist that's
just what we call our representation of
it so I mean I haven't dealt with many
physical systems when I talk about that
so what a physics shadow does that's
different than our rendering geometry is
we're not allowed to actually teleport
it from one frame to the next because if
you teleport a physics object then all
sorts of interactions that intersect
they have no previous basis to go from
of like what how to solve that they
can't like rewind time because they've
suddenly teleported into an
interpenetrating space so all of our
physics objects we give them a target of
where they need to go sorry well I'm not
our physics object physics shadows so
just like the player volume and just the
examples I'm about to give you we tell
them where we want them to go and they
try their best to apply forces and
rotations to go there but if it doesn't
work we're kind of Sol and they do their
best
so I'm replicating that for the player
over there and we're also going to
replicate it for the cubes in a second
once I get around to placing them and so
it's important to note that we're not
really solving the discontinuity in
space because that would be way too hard
at least for a person of my skill level
what we're doing is we're saying each
side has this cube over here is the
master of its physics and this cube over
here is the master of its own physics
and this cube over here is just trying
to replicate whatever this guy
doing so they don't quite line up but
they work well enough and in game
development good enough usually goes a
long way so as I'm using it you might
notice they don't quite work super well
but you can see that I've got this
representation over here I'm pushing it
in my virtual version and it's all
lining up kind of and yeah that's how we
do it in Portal so I'm gonna go ahead
and tell you that I'm really glad that
we didn't have levels with more than two
cubes because if you try to do this with
a train of cubes three or four it breaks
down horribly and this last little bit
is me just showing you that we're not
intersecting with anything in the back
of it because we're not inside the green
volume or the yellow volume because
we're behind the portal it's really
important to manage your lists of what
can interact with what when we were
faking holes in space and overlapping
space I spent a whole lot of time on
this and I think that is the end of our
physics material so we had some more
miscellaneous filler material but it
looks like we ran over a little bit of
our initial time so we're gonna open up
for Q&A now we might get to our
miscellaneous material later but yeah if
anybody's got questions now would be a
good time
so originally I had a slide on that and
oh sorry yes sorry the question was how
lights interact with portals and shadows
and things so I'm gonna preface with
saying that most of the stuff I did a
decade ago so if I say something that's
not true I'm not trying to lie I just
don't remember it so basically there was
a time during portal 1 where we've tried
very hard to make lights work through
portals and we kind of settled on a
cheap solution where we would define a
point barely in front of one portal see
what lights were projecting what amount
of color on that and just kind of making
a missive sphere on the other side that
would kind of do that so the downside
was is that you only noticed it in cases
that were very high contrast which was
also the cases where it was the most
broken so we just don't do it we did we
tried for a while to have the portals
itself project light on things and that
was also kind of broken for a while and
then we just took it out yeah so we just
punted on that one too hard
so the question was what were the
performances implications implications
of having to draw multiple scenes with
the stencil buffer so it's very
analogous to having to just draw a more
complex scene you know you're just
drawing more quads and things one of the
slides in our miscellaneous section
let's jump to it so it's very important
to so when we're rendering things in a
3d space we have what's known as a
frustum it's kind of a pyramid which
comes out from your camera and you can
use it as a very quick test to see if
you should even bother rendering
something at all so I've got the you
know I'm just gonna use my side my sides
the sides are defined by the screen
itself so you know the screen that
you're drawing has a top has a bottom so
those projecting into space so we take
our one side and we can say okay if an
object is completely on the other side
of this plane we only need to bother
trying to draw it we can just skip it
and so one of the optimizations we have
in Portal is that every time you look
through a portal we confined the frustum
to a smaller space I took the easy route
in that I kept it as an object that
still had four distinct sides so
sometimes it's a little bit broken but
in this case you can see in this case
you can see I'm looking through a blue
portal at this little button here and
I've got this it's probably impossible
to see but I've got this this mesh
coming out this is the updated frustum
of everything we should try to draw so
you can see it mostly just encapsulates
a little bit of level and the button
itself and that helps us not even
attempt to draw the complete scene over
and over again but I don't think I ever
did a performance analysis so I couldn't
give you concrete numbers but it was you
know is better than trying to draw the
entire scene over and over again because
you since we still had the depth buffer
on our side we had already drawn you
know most of the screen and we also had
the stencil buffer telling us not to
even attempt to draw most of the pixels
it was not nearly as bad as trying to
render the entire scene but we did find
that for the graphics cards of the day
which not even all of them supported
stencil buffers some people that played
portal 1 they got textures
we found it was best to just limit to
two recursions because we could do our
depth or we could do our recursion fake
and it worked pretty well and I don't
think it was terribly expensive even for
the cards of the day yeah I know there
were cases during portal 2 and we were
trying to make it work on consoles there
was a lot of protests that were for
cases especially in co-op when you're
playing in split-screen with four
portals on screen at the same time all
looking at each other there's like 16
views being rendered of the entire world
at the same time and there was these
like weird edge cases where like if you
do that you get like 2 frames a second
just don't do that so there's like that
was a few things in levels we had to
change where like the corner case was
the worst where if you have a wall like
that and you can put a portal right next
to each other on both sides of the
corner so we had a couple cases where we
had to actually change the levels to not
have those cases so you can't play so
like we just move the corners apart like
16 units or whatever so you can't always
see both portals to both the views so
there was no stuff like that that we
have to work through especially for
consoles back in the day like we were
working on ps3 and 360 s I'm sure now
it's better but it's been a long time
since we've done it if I remember
correctly using stenciling was strictly
less expensive than using textures
because you're still going to draw the
same amount of geometry but you have no
texture cost whatsoever yeah hopefully
that answers most that
how we covered our bases to make sure
the players can get stuck in levels if
they do something bad mostly through
play testing and then later on through
bug testing it's a lot of just trying to
make sure that you can see parts of the
level from different parts towards the
later process of when we're getting
positive shipping we do something called
like the greasy Pig pass for the levels
where we make sure the players can't
look like literally gets stuck on walls
and stuff as they're walking through
them so we'd have a bunch of invisible
like invisible geometry there that like
smooth the collisions along stairs and
along because especially in Portal 2
there's a bunch of these broken pieces
and a bunch of this like foliage and
broken parts of levels that are tilted
at weird angles and stuff and it's it's
like for the most part we we left them
as is but a lot of cases we had to go in
and put invisible stuff everywhere to
make sure that the wall might look like
it's broken up into like 15 different
pieces but the player is just colliding
with the flat plane it's to make sure
that in like those things don't happen
where the players doing get stuck in
spots and there's also a bunch of level
design work that goes around and making
sure because we have to take care of the
opposite as well right here take care of
like well we got to make sure the player
can't see the exit portal from the start
of the level so they can't just portal
and portal and get to the end and so
like doing that process helps with what
you're asking as well because if you can
make sure that the exploits aren't there
that you're also getting rid of cases
where the player can get themselves in a
bad spot and so it kind of works itself
out through the course of development
you don't go in starting to make a
puzzle or making a level with that in
mind a whole lot but as you start
refining it things get tweaked and
things get tuned some things maybe might
be after tweak for like first reasons
like it just doesn't work on ps3 so you
gotta be ok I got it
fix this and like tweak the puzzle a
little bit but then once you've tweaked
the puzzles now you got to do the whole
testing all over again because like all
right now I can't just put a portal
place over there because now you can
solve the puzzle without doing any of it
so there's a bunch of work that has to
go in from that
note that as we get closer to shipping a
product more and more of our dev team
switches to playtesting and we have some
very smart and mischievous people that
that specific question of like how do
you make sure you don't get stuck is on
the checklist it was on my checklist at
least have like I am going to make sure
I can't get stuck I'm gonna sit in this
level for about half an hour and think
long and hard about how to get myself
stuck and if I can't do it then pass was
there anything that we didn't pursue for
various reasons before shipping and I
can't think of anything I think I was
pretty happy with what we've produced I
most the things I focus on were bugs
that we shipped because once again
getting back into shipping mode as you
get closer to shipping something you
want to touch the code less and less and
less even if you know that the fix is
going to work 100% it'll definitely work
it might break something new so I
certainly have a small list of things
that I wished I had fixed but nothing
that I wish I yeah yeah I'm yeah I
couldn't think of any features that I'm
worked on that obviously didn't I'm
shipping some of them we touched on over
here I don't know if sticky pain was
something that we should have worked
more on though because I feel like we
spend a lot of time trying to get it to
work and the reasons for cutting it then
are still valid now so like I'm saying I
give if we were to go back I don't think
we would try to solve that problem we
have probably come up with new problems
to try to solve we did have like another
thing we tried was I think we tried it
after the game shipped and for like a
DLC expansion was reflection paint so it
was paint that would reflect the
different elements of the game so I
could flecked lasers or reflect light
bridges we didn't get too far with it
again like it leads to a bunch of
different like weird levels cuz you have
to have all levels have angles because
if you think about portal emotional
levels are like 90-degree walls and
stuff and 90 degree reflections don't go
anywhere
so like we have to have like make this
super contrived looking levels with
these weird 45-degree angles everywhere
and they can reflect things and then
there's other problems like well how
often like how many bounces do we allow
on things like and like also the stuff
just looked weird like tractor beams
reflecting off of walls just look weird
there's probably other ideas that I
can't remember right now but there was a
like a lot of them get cut short pretty
quick because the the flaws are really
apparent pretty quickly like you might
sit down and think oh this is a great
idea I'm going to go and work on it and
then as you start working through it and
testing it out with others you you start
seeing all the problems and and those
problems get apparent pretty quickly and
at that point you make the call just
yeah this is not worth pursuing anymore
we had some more game modes we work
we're trying to work on I think we had
like a competitive mode for a little bit
we worked on yeah we actually had a
slide about that for a little bit it
didn't get fleshed out but after portal
shipped we immediately said to herself
what does multiplayer look like and so
the first thing we tried was deathmatch
turns out that's a horrible idea
everybody wants to just put portals
under other people's feet so you spend
most of your time just completely
disoriented too confused and then I
think we made a like a collect the coins
kind of like oh do flings and things but
once again everybody wanted to put their
portals under other people's feet so now
we have co-op very successful I think
and there's a bunch of other challenges
that come with co-op that we had to work
through I think we yeah we tried some
more different competitive modes we
tried like a time trial kind of mode but
they're doing it together
but that's effectively just playing two
single-player games at the same time so
there's not much in track because any
time you let present track in a
competitive way in portal they just want
to put portals on the feet like that's
really all they want to do and it's fun
for a bit but not as the receiving end
right like it's not fun or or they just
want to keep bumping each other's
portals like when they want to put their
portal exactly what the other guy's
portal is so like they walk in and they
go in there and sort of where they were
supposed to go it's fun for a bit I'm
not saying there's no matter there
I think means about five minutes yeah a
bit I guess it's a you looking like ah
that's funny
but then you realize like there's no
real at least in the mechanics we tried
there wasn't much depth to it it's not
something you could flesh out for a
game-mode it's more of something you
could do as like a level as a gimmick
once but then there's there's not much
reason to do that like and this the cost
to doing that is really high so you have
to figure out like do you want to spend
a bunch of dev effort in making this
gimmick that's gonna get really old and
half the people are gonna get annoyed
and frustrated so you just don't do that
in the back there
the the question reference is how there
were some pipeline restraints on the the
pixel queries and if there were any
hacks that we had to do to meet
performance I believe yes yeah once
again we have to say that I did most of
this about ten years ago I can't think
of anything off the top my head there
wasn't a whole lot we did stuff for the
paint I don't know if we did a bunch of
hacks but I wanted the big hacks on the
paint that we did was the paint that
you're seeing is not the paint that's
doing the painting so I mean that's like
nobody can tell it's pretty good but you
know especially on the on multiplayer
the paint that the client is seeing is
not the paint of the server seeing
because we couldn't transmit all that
data so they both generating their own
paint data but then the server is the
only one doing the actual painting so
all the blobs that the client is hitting
on in the world do nothing and the
server blobs do the painting and then
tell the client paint over there paint
over there so that's that's the kind of
thing because the network bandwidth is
pretty limited and there's a lot of
paint flying through the world so we had
to we couldn't just transmit all the
paint all the time so they all generate
their own paint blobs that are through
the world and then the painting itself
happened on the server and then that
gets transmitted but the paint flying
through the air is different on every
one but it's it's random enough that you
can't really tell
um no comment prob probably not in all
seriousness so after the initial portal
came out one of the other experiments
was not only multi what does multiplayer
look like but well how how fun is this
in a halflife environment and it turns
out that the the way that half-life is
made there are a whole lot of slightly
scripted sequences to make things work
and so the way those levels are designed
are fundamentally different than portal
levels and they basically just break
down so if there were portals in
half-life the half-life would seem a lot
more like portal think about a portal
level it's pretty constrained the sight
lines are pretty constrained the level
takes place in a box you can't see
really far and there's a lot of kinks in
the walls so you can't like see all the
way to the end half-life levels aren't
designed like that at all so you would
just go on a level and like portal all
the way to the exit and then skip all
the gameplay which I mean there's
probably mods that allow you to do that
but like I think the games themselves
and the mechanics are fundamentally
different enough that I don't think they
interact really well unless both of them
change or one of them changes a lot so
it's not no longer what the game you
want is I think you were a first-year
so the question was asking about our
student game projects so Dave work we
both went to a school in Redmond called
DigiPen Dave went there before I did I
graduated in 2005 so I worked on a game
called narbacular drop which if you
google it for it you it will be the only
results because the name was chosen so
that would be the only result on Google
if you can spell it good luck and so
that was our senior project in at
DigiPen my team at the time and so we
ended up through a very convoluted long
story showing that at valve and they
hired us on the spot to basically
recreate those mechanics for them and
that was actually there wasn't a whole
lot of confidence at the time if that
would actually ship but it became portal
so it seems like a good thing yeah and I
was part of a team that made tag the
power of paint the video I showed with
the paint gun and that was our team's a
junior project at DigiPen and same thing
I think valve saw it a couple times and
hired the entire team to come work on on
that's that mechanic at valve and then
once we got there it became obvious to
try to integrate it into portal 2 and
that's how we started working on portal
2 and that's how the portal 2 gels came
about
what about how the story in the game
mechanics interact and how one affects
the other so the way the way at least
important to and I think portal 1 was
very similar the way it kind of works at
valve is we we don't really have an
overarching design for the for like a
design doc for the game before we start
it's a lot of smaller things that we try
to then combine using similar techniques
like what we discussed today and and the
story kind of builds our out of that
using the same techniques because the
way we we kind of wear out most of our
design decisions is by play testing and
the story follows a very similar paths
but you don't really want one either one
to override the other because if if you
see the game like if I make a bunch of
if we have a team that made a bunch of
puzzles for the game that haven't been
very play tested and then like the
writer comes in and does a bunch of
writing for it and then you realize
three weeks later that oh half these
levels aren't shipping anymore because
they didn't test well then you're you
made a bunch of dependencies that don't
really work portal was was lucky in that
the puzzles themselves are
compartmentalized as like you enter the
elevator or you exit the elevator you do
a puzzle like enter the elevator so
they're all pretty compartmentalized and
a lot of the writing that was done for
it was essentially just jokes so a lot
of those jokes do fit in to most of the
puzzles so the puzzle can change and the
joke can just be inserted into it but
for the overarching story of the game I
think that required a lot more
collaboration so the the writers were
on-site like there they were valve
employees and they were sitting in the
same room as as watching the play tests
bouncing back and forth ideas and we
used we had GLaDOS for most of the game
and the voice artist was local so we had
her come in many times and record a
bunch of lines we also used some like
fake online
robot voice for a while but those those
are hard to judge because the play
tester is almost never laugh at those
jokes
because because the robot voice doesn't
really know how to speak them but it
sounds like a robot so it's it's not
it's better than nothing it's better
than just putting text on the screen
which we also did for a while so like
with the with the writing there's two
things you're trying to test right
you're trying to test out their
individual jokes and a lot of them can
be transplanted to any level so they're
not super depending on the levels but
then once the story starts coming
together and starts taking shape at that
point you're making changes to the
levels to accommodate the story and from
that point on you have to have a pretty
good amount of confidence that these
particular levels are going to ship in
the game and so that that starts
happening I think fairly late into the
into our dev cycle at least there's
always an overarching goal there's
always a goal of like you're trying to
capture Wheatley or you're trying to go
kill GLaDOS but the exact mechanics of
how that happens doesn't come together
until fairly late because you don't want
to spend a bunch of time integrating
your story and your levels without
having a bunch of confidence that these
levels are actually good enough to ship
which which we do have for a bunch of
the game but as new levels and new
mechanics are being introduced it all
kind of goes haywire so it's just mostly
just a pretty strong collaborative
process between the writers and the
designers and it all goes back to the
play testing
so the question was how sound interacts
with portal and I my memory is a little
fuzzy I'm pretty sure we tried to
replicate a little bit using just a
simple basically the exact same solution
as with our lighting where it's like we
have a sample point in front of a portal
and we have an emitter on the other side
I can't remember if we shipped that way
yeah microphone or ingame microphone and
an in-game speaker on the portals so on
both sides so if you're on this side of
the portal you'll hear what's happening
another side I pretty sure that's how we
shipped yeah but I don't think we made
any special concessions to make it seem
like it was going through a tunnel or
anything like that we just want to make
sure you could hear what's going on not
through the portal specifically I know
there's a bunch of stuff we did for like
the tractor beam like when you're into
the tractor beam it kind of puzzles like
everything else around you and like like
models the sound a little bit but going
through the portals themselves I don't
think there's anything specific we did
there are these granted I it's been a
long time I've been alone
portal
the question was what puzzles games
inspired us when we were making our game
I I can't think of a strong information
so I'm mostly a code guy so I didn't do
a whole lot of the actual like puzzle
design but when I'm thinking back we
didn't have a whole lot of sources to
draw on because it was a fairly new
concept in general yeah I can't think of
any sources I drew and I mean yeah yeah
I wasn't kidding when I said portal when
we are making tag
I think portal had come out a year or
two earlier before that and was really
good and like a big success and we were
trying to learn from how they were
teaching the players different things
and that's one of the biggest things we
took away in our student game was like
how do you teach players different
mechanics and I think portal did a
really good job of that by like teaching
by doing instead of by showing so you
like the players doing all the stuff and
then figuring it out instead of someone
showing a video or just telling the
player here's what you do next and then
going doing that so we tried to like
take that at heart and as we were doing
in our game introducing new paints and
new mechanics doing it the same way
where we introduced them in a way that
the usage is obvious enough that the
player will try it out and when they try
it out and it works they feel really
good about it
because they feel like they figured it
out instead of us doing all the work and
showing them what to do so it's like a
lot of that kind of that was the
specific thing that we took from portal
and trying to do it in our game
so the question was about how many
people it took to make portal and portal
1 portal and portal to portal 1 was a
pretty small team yes for the most part
yeah so portal 2 started as the seven
people that worked on the student game
yeah sorry portal one started with the
seven people that worked on narbacular
drop directly transplanted and then we
started working fairly early with two
writers and you know we were leveraging
other people that Valve to answer
questions and help us you know hit the
ground running as far as how to use the
engine but it was mostly just the the
nine people working day to day and then
portal 2 ballooned quite a bit portal 2
was a much bigger team by the time I
joined valve in 2009 I think there was
already a pretty big portal 2 team
they'd already had a field of mechanics
figured out the game was pretty
different from what we see now but at
that point it was already maybe 10 12
people and then like it slowly increased
like we were four of us that got hired
for our paint game so we joined that
team and then I think by the end of it
they were probably close to 40 50 people
working on it that was towards the very
end because we had to ship on to cons on
like two consoles and PC and we had a
whole co-op mechanic and there was a
whole co-op campaign being worked on
separately as well as single-player one
so it was a pretty big team by the end
of it much bigger than portal 1 and the
game itself I think is much bigger than
portal 1 as well I think the
single-player campaign itself is
probably more than twice as long
yeah I remember and in the campaign as a
co-op one is probably also that big
remember in portal 1 we would have to do
frequent integration testing and I think
I got my play time on portal 1 down to
like 45 minutes and
portal 2 is several hours yeah so it's a
much bigger game so it took a lot more
people in compared to something like
unity for both portal and portal 2 we
used source which is our in-house game
engine and it's very different from how
unity works so the way unity works is
mostly kind of like a WYSIWYG editor
like what you're seeing in the editor is
the game essentially like all the
entities and stuff are loaded obviously
more stuff gets loaded at runtime but
what you're seeing is what you're
getting whereas the way source works is
it's got a bunch of these discrete tools
that that make stuff so there's a level
editor which is where you make your
level and then you import that into the
game and you run the game separately and
what you're seeing in the level editor
is not what's what you're seeing in the
game because a lot of the entities and
stuff don't translate to the editor a
lot of the lighting and stuff has to be
pre-baked unity has some pre big
lighting as well but in the way it
worked on source source is I think it's
a combination of a bunch of like
discrete tools for each different aspect
of the game so I get a separate
particles editor a separate model editor
separate editor for like vo and the face
poser and the separate level editor and
then there's a game engine that like
takes the compiled versions of all like
compiled outputs of all those things and
then puts them in the game engine and
combines them together and then all the
code is pretty much exclusively C++ I
don't think there's really anything else
there might be a couple like handful of
things that are not but all the tools
are C++ all the game engine all the
runtime code it's all C++ source 2 is a
little bit different but still going
forward on that front it's like I'm not
trying to do what unity is doing because
unity is more of
you're running scripts see c-sharp
scripts and then you're just compiling
them wild editor is going and and they
rapid iteration and stuff source doesn't
really have that same model of working
but the around it is that like we
control all of it and then the like the
ceiling for what we can produce is
theoretically quite a bit higher so
there's this trade-offs to it and also
we we make all our tools and all our end
in stuff in-house so and we're where the
primary customer for it like our games
so we're not trying to do what unity is
doing and trying to service to anyone
out there who wants to make anything and
and unity has like thousands of people
working on their engine and we have
quite a few orders of magnitude lists
but but like I think we're aware of all
the trade-offs we're making we're not
we're not like trying not to do what
they're doing we're just seeing one
we're learning from them too and source
two we've taken a few cues from stuff
like unity and stuff like unreal trying
to be more user friendly even to our own
customers like internal employees but
it's not like the the way of working is
very different between source and unity
I think we're good all right well yeah
thanks thanks again for tomorrow so much
for coming so there's some extra pizza
outside but that was portal problem so
thank you very much